A specter is haunting Western sexual
relations the Specter of the Trad wife
sounds pretty nice sounds really great
this video is brought to you by Jen you
sell more from them in just a little bit
first though tick tocks from Libs
hungry at women who don't want to be
lives take it away
[Music]
um
it's giving blood and soil
like
you know
like is it from the Nazi women's
magazine or is it from 2020 to tick tock
like I just can't tell who knows I just
think that if I was part of a movement
that had a lot of crossover with
fascists and neo-nazis and Nazi culture
I would probably make sure that my
propaganda for my lifestyle did not like
emulate
the 1920s and 30s do you know like what
I mean
just just how I do stuff though you know
so right now
you're a single guy
you gotta pick one of those two women to
be your wife who do you pick I'm not
even saying based on looks obviously the
Trad wife looks very very pretty and the
other woman possibly could be pretty but
she was not trying to make herself look
very pretty and she was trying to make
herself seem you know apathetic and
speaking in that way the Millennials do
in the vocal fry which is just an
expression of apathy because you're not
even putting your breath underneath your
voice and it's oh there's a Trad wife
all happy making a pie or whatever she's
doing dolled up looking good and then
her argument the argument for why her
way of life which does not seem to be
leading her to very much flourishing she
doesn't just doesn't seem that happy the
Trad wife seems very happy you know the
tree buys fruits her argument as to why
you should not be the Trad wife or like
the Trad wife is that if you are
traditional
if you are married to a husband and you
have traditional women's roles you're
basically a Nazi step one
get married and cook for your husband
step two
step three you're a Nazi I think you you
might need to flesh out that idea a
little bit more hit you know Hitler
drank water do you want to drink why are
you drinking water uh I wouldn't choose
my beverages based on what people did in
the 1930s Germany okay next lib I just
got done doing an interview deep diving
the entire Trad wife movement because
although I love the aesthetic and I am a
stay-at-home mom I do not believe A
Woman's Place is in service to her man
or her household so when we were
discussing the Trad wives and why it's
connected to the alt-right a realization
came to my head that I had not yet made
the connection between the reason why
Trad wives and so-called like
traditional women can be so dangerous is
because they believe it is not just
their place to be in service to their
husbands and their homes it is women's
place to be in service to their husband
in their homes the difference between
individual choice and natural position
is what makes it dangerous because men
have been able to hold those
misogynistic views forever and only
recently has ISM pushed back against it
but when it is a woman who holds these
ideologies to be truth she has now
emboldened an entire score of
misogynistic men to go forth and
subjugate women on the premise that that
is their place I don't like the Trad
wives because they're trying to force
their view of what women should do on me
that's not the particulars of their
lifestyle it's that they're trying to
force their view of how women should
behave on me which is getting in the way
of me trying to force my views of how
women should behave on them
you're both trying to do that you're
saying that feminism is the only
legitimate Way Forward for women at
least at a political level and that the
Trad wives are hostile to feminism
they're very dangerous we need to be
very wary of them and and discourage
them from being traditional she's
demonstrating the point we live in a
society some view or other is going to
predominate and so it can either be the
angry feminist view or it can be the
happy Trad wife you or I guess some
other view that is has not been raised
yet but if I had to choose between those
two probably the traditional way is best
more from the libs and the Trad wives in
one second first though people are
raving about genucel skin care Jessica
from Huntsville Alabama says my skin
looks so soft and clear I've seen a
reduced number of fine lines and dark
spots I found a new lifetime product
absolutely love it Jen you sell skin
care uses a one of a kind proprietary
flower base developed by the founder and
pharmacist who is a great guy by the way
it's also comes along with rare
Botanical extracts and Powerful
antioxidants for skin care results that
work guaranteed I said I would not
endorse the product if I could not try
it if I were not impressed by the
product and also fellas I know sometimes
men are a little skeptical of getting
into Cosmetics too much even slightly
more men than women use genuscal and for
good reason geniusell's most popular
package is available to you today for
seventy percent off 7-0 at genucel.com
Knowles y T join millions of happy
customers who've already fallen in love
with the results Plus for a limited time
get genuine cells probiotic extract
moisturizer free with every most popular
package go to genucel.com knowlesyt
genucel.com knowlesyt
okay so you guys know the term Trad wife
it's gotten really popular in the last
few years the alt-right super into it
conservatives love it
but I just I don't think enough of you
know that it started out as a porn
term it started out being used for
mostly erotica
erotica writers use the term Trad wife
to categorize
pornography
and now they like use it seriously is
that true I don't know if I believe that
I guess I'll have to take her word for
it but I don't know that I believe that
because you'll sometimes hear this about
the word cuckold they'll say the word
or cuckold that actually comes from
a category of pornography and I know for
a fact that isn't true because I happen
to be of Italian extraction and the term
cuckold is one of the earliest insults
it's one of the longest standing insults
you can use in Italian
and it actually it's symbolized and
sometimes you'll see Italians wear a
necklace with what looks like a little
Chili Pepper there or that you'll see
the sign like the rock and roll sign
that that derives from the same symbol
and it's it's the sign to ward off the
malocchio so that you don't become a
cornuto and so calling someone a I
mean that's a that's a very old old term
you see an English literature too when
the libs say it's from pornography I
they might think it might have something
to do with pornography now but and they
might think it has something it derived
from pornography but the only reason
they think that is because the only
thing that they know about art
literature or culture is pornography
that's the main sort of cultural product
that they are they are imbibing so it's
not surprising that they don't
understand that these things have have
much longer history I would not
recommend
basing your lifestyle off of pornography
but I wouldn't recommend
totally denying or ignoring your sexual
desires either sex is a powerful thing
and our erotic impulses actually ought
to be
encouraged they just have to be directed
to the right place I mean ultimately all
of our desires are are erotic desires
our desires for friendship our
intellectual desires our desires for
wisdom all of those ultimately are to be
a a way of turning our souls toward God
the source and Summit of all good so
that's a long way of saying even if this
does have some porn tie and well it
doesn't matter what that says about the
pornography industry it matters what it
says about human desire there might be a
reason that human beings have this
desire and it might not necessarily be
totally disordered even if whatever the
porn iteration of this is has all sorts
of nasty terrible things to it there
might be some kernel there where men
want women who are like women and women
women like men who are like men I am the
role model that I want my daughter to
have traditional wise
need to consider what traditions they
are upholding I do not find fulfillment
in being a wife and a mother I love my
husband and my child dearly but if they
were my entire world my mental health
would tank I am so glad that I was late
to becoming a wife and a mother or at
least late by Evangelical standards
because it gave me time to find out who
I was before I took on the role of being
something to someone else some women do
find fulfillment in being a wife and a
mother but pushing traditional gender
roles arms those of us who do not or do
not want to fit into your little box
she seems happy doesn't she I don't want
to make fun of her she's I love she says
I'm really happy with all the choices
I've made in life yeah wow in that
imagine imagine
wait what did that caption say
babies too though I don't okay now she's
getting ready
and then she did laundry getting ready
and doing laundry or human things not
feminine things what else does this girl
think I do not know how to operate the
laundry machine in my home I don't know
how to do it
I have on maybe a couple of occasions
when my wife said oh could you go put
the laundry in I have done it I have had
to ask her to guide me every step of the
way that is not something that comes
naturally
to men that is a little more of a
feminine thing I would have to say keep
going the 1950s does she not know the
Civil Rights and voting acts right until
the 60s
some white people man I don't know if
she's talking about for
like the civil rights movement that
changed a number of structures in our
country but if she's talking about women
and feminism
we women did have the vote long before
the 1950s interesting discussion to be
had on that that whole history but uh
okay keep going all right well I'm
sucked in now so let's see what else
um what
only land owning males should vote no
but you specifically should not vote
anyway is that Bronte remsic
oh that's my old friend Bronte
well I couldn't I thought she looks kind
of familiar that's the gal who you you
may recall I had a long interview with
on the topic of abortion there was a
clip that went very very viral from it
in in which she referred to pregnant
persons and I I said you mean mothers
and she said maybe that includes mothers
but there are other people and she
couldn't so who other than mothers who
can be pregnant and she was sort of
stumped by that question okay keep going
a woman's tattoo
if you love being a stay-at-home mom
good for you why should we all be
expected to do that I don't what they
didn't even bother to be the cartoon
look happy
I may not be a smart man she's just
roasting herself at this point hmm well
in deference to my great friendship with
Bronte remsick I won't be too harsh in
my critique of this but suffice it to
say Bronte perhaps a well-intentioned as
she is remains confused on a number of
topics my favorite of course would have
to be that first woman who said that if
you doll yourself up and are Pleasant
and happy and you have a good family you
are a Nazi that that pretty much sums up
political discussion in the year of Our
Lord 2023. great job I encourage all of
you Trad wives out there keep it up and
I encourage all the liberal women you
might want to reconsider
I Wanna Lose
[Music]
I want a little sweetness down in my
soul